my name is Angus Trumbull and I'm senior
curator of paintings and sculpture here
at the Yale Center for British art at
first book a brief history of the smile
began when I was asked to give a talk at
a conference of dentists and after that
the dentists doctors and dentists talk
to each other so the dentist's
recommended me to the orthopedic
surgeons who were having a conference
about sports injuries and I was asked to
give a talk at that conference and so I
gave a talk about gesture and that is
what led me ultimately to write the
finger a handbook quite a big chunk of
my book is about pointing rude pointing
useful pointing pointing to indicate but
also pointing as a technique of military
command which is very ancient here in
this marvelous portrait of Admiral Lord
Bridport we see pointing used for both
military command and indication because
with the same hand the Admiral points to
his flagship the royal gorge in the
background this is an actress mrs.
abington portrayed by sir joshua
reynolds in the part of miss peru in
Congreve's love for love which was a
Restoration comedy that enjoyed a very
successful revival in the later 18th
century a lot of the book is about body
language but there's also a lot in that
about the thumb and one of the original
questions that i started with is is the
thumb or finger and i'm pleased to say
that that question was answered
resoundingly in the affirmative the
thumb is the finger that put us on top
of the evolutionary tree it's a
possibility which with each of the other
digits is the top makes the hand that
the marvelous tool that it is in this
picture though we see the thumb deployed
as a sort of fascinator the way miss
Paroo plays
the thumb over her lower lip is a
marvelously sensual device deployed by
Reynolds with very disarming subtle tea
in this representation of the sense of
touch the artist philippe Mercier
divides the composition into two halves
a pair of lovers on the right and
another pair who have been disrupted by
an angry cat that scratched the young
man's hand pain and pleasure the sense
of touch is is is an important
protagonist in in my book and it was the
sense of touch that as far back as
Aristotle gave the ancients the hardest
time to make sense of the eyes were
clearly the seat of vision the ears were
clearly the seat of hearing the nose was
clearly the siege of smell but Aristotle
had great difficulty deciding where it
was exactly that the organ which organ
was that touch related to he decided
deprived of any knowledge of the central
nervous system he decided on the heart
happenstance and serendipity played a
big part in in this project but there's
a larger principle as well because if
you cut deeply enough into one narrow
seam of human experience or in this case
Anatomy hopefully you going access to
rather more and it was my hope that by
writing a book about fingers I could
allow in the end the finger itself to
point to various interesting profound
and intriguing aspects of us